it's a tuesday edition of pft pm
recording a little bit early today just
because i want to articulate some
thoughts about the patrick mahomes
contract i've written about this at
profootballtalk.com
i want to explain in further detail why
i believe what i believe about the
mahomes contract and my broad belief is
he shouldn't sign it and patrick if
you're listening and the chances that
you're listening are slim and none if
you haven't signed it yet don't sign it
a 12-year commitment is way too long of
a contract for a player of his skill and
ability to sign i'm talking to you now
not him i've given up on talking to him
because i know he's not listening
but here's the bottom line
he's the best player in football right
now
potentially potentially the best player
of all time we'll find out in the coming
years
and in the coming 12 years the chiefs
have exclusive control over his rights
he can't get out for 12 years he can't
force his way back to the table
over the course of the next 12 years
sure he can hold out at some point he
doesn't seem like the type that would
hold out but he could if he gets to a
point where he looks around in 2027 2028
and realizes that that contract with a
new money average of 45 million dollars
per year pales in comparison to somebody
we haven't even heard of yet
who may be making 60 million per year at
the time and the salary cap may be north
of 300 million maybe 400 million per
year at the time
there's too much uncertainty over the
way the game is going to change over the
way the money is going to grow and in
some respects
the chief's got him at a perfect time
because right now the uncertainty skews
negative
we're looking at the pandemic we don't
know what's going to happen we don't
know when things are going to be normal
again well at some point they will be
and when they are normal there will be
plenty of people spending plenty of
money and plenty of time watching
football
and
as states throughout the country try to
repair their budgets after the pandemic
the reality is this
there will be legalized gambling coast
to coast there'll be exceptions utah
beyond that
hell maybe even utah will give in and
allow legalized gambling because that's
a way to make back a lot of money and
everyone's losing money state and
federal governments are losing money and
everyone else for the most part is
losing money during this pandemic the
legalized gambling will spread more
money will be made by the nfl more money
will be made by the teams everything
will get larger and larger and larger
and larger except from home's contract
10-year 450 million dollar extension
12-year 477 million dollar contract
think about that for a second it's not a
half billion dollar deal it's not
i may be the only person in the media
who will say to you it's not a half
billion dollar deal 477 it close
close enough
it's not a half billion it gets to a
half billion with 25 million in
incentives two and a half million per
year spread out over 10 years and we
don't know what it takes to get
to the two and a half million maybe it's
easy maybe he's got to be the mvp of the
league or the super bowl mvp every year
to get the two and a half million we
don't know
i just feel like
somebody wanted to say
here's a half billion dollar contract
the first half billion dollar contract
in all of sports
the problem is
by the time we get to
the second half of the contract
there's a good chance patrick mahomes is
going to be feeling some regret there's
a good chance he's going to be feeling
like he's not being paid fairly and
if push comes to shut there's nothing he
can do about it and see the problem is
before you even get to the point where
you complain about this deal
you have to be willing to acknowledge to
the world
maybe i shouldn't have signed the deal
that's the first
hurdle see that that's that's the genius
of this deal that's why the chiefs
employees were out looking for champagne
yesterday this is a great deal for them
and this is a deal that there's a good
chance patrick mahomes will never
say i have regrets over it even if he
does
think about it
and i thi this is the jon voight's car
example remember the seinfeld episode
where
the
uh george costanza decision was made to
buy the car that was owned by john
voight and there was a question as to
whether or not it was really jon voight
the actor and and he kept doubling down
and digging in because he didn't want to
look foolish
see players will be inclined to double
down and dig in on contracts that they
shouldn't have signed because the first
step is to admit maybe i shouldn't have
done this
and i'm telling you
he shouldn't have done it no great
player should sign a 12-year contract
there's no reason to do it because you
quickly get to the point in the life of
the contract where it's a one-way deal
we talk about this all the time the team
has the right to rip it up anytime they
want the player has no right to rip it
up the player is stuck the team isn't
now the guarantee mechanisms a word that
had never been used before in the 20
years i've been covering the nfl
basically a series of roster bonuses
built into the contract every year good
move forces the chiefs to make an early
decision instead of squatting on patrick
mahomes until september they have to
make a decision in march every year
nothing wrong with that
but
that
first of all it's not guaranteed money
477 million in guarantee mechanisms all
that means is there's a roster bonus
every year that forces the chiefs to
make a decision early
and if the decision is we no longer
think that his skills and abilities
justify what we're supposed to pay him
that's when he gets cut and that's when
he has to go out and find something else
that's when he becomes a free agent but
the reality is he only becomes a free
agent if his play has diminished to the
point where the chiefs look at what
they're do to pay him and they say
he's not worth this anymore so if he's
not worth that to the chiefs he's not
going to be worth out to anybody else
there's no reason to do a 12-year deal
there really isn't
and i'm trying to understand why
he agreed to it
my advice to patrick mahomes would have
been this
wait
you're due to make 27.63 million over
the next two years
wait
franchise tag exclusive franchise tag
which is what surely would be extended
to mahomes come
early 2020
two
would be well north of 30 million
dollars this year for deck press got the
exclusive tag 31.4
in two years it may be 35 maybe more
wait
20 raise over that for 2023 44 raise
over that for 2024. wait
add up those numbers
for 2021
also 2020 the 27.63 million for the next
two years three years of the tag five
years do that math
that's what you're reasonably looking at
getting barring some sort of an injury
that derails your career and causes the
chiefs not to exercise the franchise
tech
on top of that you've got great
endorsement money that's coming in the
the best player in the nfl one of the
most popular players in the nfl
endorsements out the wazoo for patrick
mahomes that's one of the reasons zack
prescott has waited his endorsement
portfolio you get an insurance policy to
protect you against a career ending
injury now look the the problem with
insurance policies like that are number
one they're very expensive and number
two good luck trying to get the money
when it's time to cash in because it has
to be a truly career-ending injury
those don't happen very often to
quarterbacks and then you can try to get
a loss of value policy where you would
argue well the contract i eventually got
was worth a lot less than it would have
been good luck proving that too see the
problem with insurance companies is this
their commodity is money so they want to
take in as much money as they can they
want to pay out as little money as they
can that's their commodity they have no
products they have no goods it's money
let's take in as much as we can let's
pay out as little as we can and the last
thing they want to do is pay out these
gigantic policies that go to
professional athletes but still still it
gives you protection against a truly
catastrophic outcome that prevents you
from ever playing again so you look at
the bird in the hand you look at your
path year to year under the franchise
tag you look at your endorsement money
you have faith in your ability to
continue to play at a high level
and you just wait
now
what's he getting return for that
he's traded in
27.63 million plus his ability to go
year to year under the franchise tag for
a contract that pays out 63 million
fully guaranteed at signing or one
million more fully guaranteed than what
ryan tannehill got on a four-year
contract with the tennessee titans
is 63 million fully guaranteed at
signing enough to justify a 12-year
commitment the easy answer to that
question is no way in hell it's not
it never is
so i'm still trying to understand why
this was done
and there's some speculation in league
circles that lee steinberg who isn't
known
currently although maybe he currently
now is as a
high-level quarterback contract
negotiator there's some concern that if
they had waited two years to do the
mahomes deal
maybe mahomes decides to jump to another
agency maybe after caa gets a mega deal
for dak prescott mahomes says i think
i'd like them to do my deal
or if deshawn watson gets a great deal
from the texans a three-year deal that
pays him a ton of money but gets him
back to the trough sooner rather than
later maybe mahomes decides to go to
athletes first
maybe after russell wilson gets his next
deal
mahomes decides that he's going to hire
the baseball agent too hey i played
baseball mark rogers the baseball agent
with one client has done great work for
russell wilson getting him market
setting deals maybe i'll maybe i'll hire
him
that's a real dynamic i mean i'm gonna
peel the curtain back that's a very real
dynamic for agents they're always
worried about someone stealing their
clients and if somebody would come in
and get patrick mahomes to go sign with
them or even if mahomes just decides on
his own
i'm going to go with someone else
you don't make any future money
now lee steinberg and his firm are fully
vested in whatever percentage they're
getting
of that 477 million over the next 12
years that's a nice annuity payment
that's a nice that's a nice
check that arrives every year from
patrick mahomes under this deal that
pays out 45 million per year in new
money on the 10-year extension
so just something to think about
just just part of the reality of the
agent business in the national football
league doing the deal now
locks in the fee for 12 years waiting
for two years
runs the risk that someone else may end
up being the one who does the long-term
deal for patrick mahomes
there's plenty of other angles and
plenty of other wrinkles and things that
i haven't even thought about yet that
i'll think about
at some point and i'll either write
about it or we'll talk about it again
tomorrow but but but seriously
this isn't a criticism of patrick
mahomes he hired the agents to do the
deal you have to defer to your agents
they're the doctor they're the expert
you need to trust them
i just don't know how you reconcile
the talent that patrick holmes has with
a 12-year commitment that puts the full
control in the hands of the team beyond
the first couple of years there's no
reason to do this
none whatsoever well he wants to stay in
kansas city well that's fine he can want
to stay in kansas city but kansas city
has to want him
this is not a two-way commitment kansas
city can say we're done with you at any
time after we get past the first couple
years you know what even then
the cap hits aren't that
significant
if something happened look it's likely
not going to happen
but the chiefs have full flexibility
they have full control they decide how
long this lasts
this is not something that secures
patrick home's future in kansas city it
secures kids the city's future with
patrick mahomes for as long as they want
it up to 12 years that's why they bought
that champagne yesterday folks
what does this mean for dak prescott
i put the question out on twitter today
would the cowboys offer dak prescott the
patrick mahomes deal right now
and if so
would patrick mahomes deal be accepted
by dak prescott i have to let you know
macy's just walked into the room i
thought the door was closed so she's in
here sniffing around there's a chance
you'll see her she's under the desk
right now she thinks i may have dropped
some food i may have dropped some potato
chips last night so we're just going to
keep this rolling this is a new
experience macy can you please move
there she's finally moved you may see
her in the background there she is i can
see her back there anyway
uh and i don't think she's been out to
use the bathroom today so there's a
chance she may bark at some point but
with dak prescott i don't believe he
would take this deal for one very
obvious reason he's not going to commit
for 12 years he'd much rather take i
believe the ryan tannehill contract four
years 118 million by the way tan hill
over the next four years is gonna make
more than patrick mahomes
tannehill got 62 million fully
guaranteed at signing
mahomes got 63 million fully guaranteed
it signed i think between the two deals
dak would take tannehill over mahomes we
know dak only wants to do a four year
deal
so
what does this mean for dak prescott
look
it ultimately means nothing
because prescott's got
34 point note 31.4 million in hand for
this year
37.6 8 million in hand for next year if
they tag him again and then the
opportunity to hit the open market or
get a 44 raise for 2022. i've been
saying all along the cowboys
have to offer him something that will
get him to trade in what he could make
this year next year and come 2022
whether they tag him again at a 44 raise
or they let him become a free agent
patrick mahomes deal means nothing
to dak prescott now here's the problem
because the best player in football has
done
this 12-year deal what's going to happen
to these other quarterbacks they're
going to have to deal with this
comparison you're going to hear
that teams will be saying to players
well you know patrick mahomes what makes
you think you deserve a better deal than
he got we want you to sign a 12-year
deal it was good enough for my homes it
should be good enough for you
now that's that's probably not going to
work but it complicates life for the
agents who are trying to negotiate these
long-term deals for quarterbacks moving
forward 12 years should not become the
norm the deals need to be shorter
especially as we move toward a world
where everything is going to increase
it's hard to see past the pandemic but
there is a future beyond the pandemic
and once we get there the numbers are
going to go up
and
whether he admits it or not patrick
mahomes is going to regret
having signed a deal that commits him to
the chiefs for 12 years but doesn't
commit the chiefs to him for 12 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports